on va faire un jeu et je vais vous
expliquer le jeu vous pouvez tout de
suite miser sur un des chroniqueurs et
celui qui aura misé sur le bon
chroniqueur gagnera et j'improvise
totalement gagnera allez on offre à 1 le
dernier smartphone le dernier le dernier
smartphone 3d pmp pétanque avec le nom
du chroniqueur d'accord pmp tempe
fracassé l'annoncé tapez pétanqueurs la
lâcheté heisbourg laval et asseyez vous
et le shérif c'est très simple on va
jouer à la pétanque et commence à petits
pas pleuvoir mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas la petite bête qui va manger la
grosse pression mais ça vous aurez deux
boules chacun n'ont d'ailleurs non vous
n'aurez qu'une boule ça brasse cependant
j'avais une boule à chaque fois les deux
derniers seront éliminés le truc c'est
il faut être le plus près des zones dans
lesquelles on les casse et si vous
cassez à 9 vous était au jeu tout de
suite au plus près de là ces parties de
ligue 1
[Musique]
m
hier aignan et le gagnant je rajoute je
rajoute donc jeudi un smartphone le
dernier smartphone plus une brique à
neuf après les fêtes de pessah
voilà je vous laisse car les battre pour
mes jambes et tactiquement dégagé le
compas dans l'oeil pour cette faute là
ne vous inquiétez pas si vous n'avez pas
remporter toutes les antennes relais les
cherry lane et bénabar à jour adp
gagnait un truc il a bien sûr un truc
pour le gagnant est le grand gagnant
désignera celui qui sera en cochonné
pendant toute l'émission et qui devra
démarrer toutes ses phrases marque c'est
comme ça ben hassine attention c'est
parti on va des valeurs on va laisser
des marais les filles honneur aux filles
isabelle lavoie souhaitant pas commencé
mais va bien a lâché riba 6 et andorra
isa au nord il a les filles nées là s'il
vous avait battu j'avais ci-dessus
classé pour le maître c'est pour le xv
au boulou vous étiez très vague normes
année sur une zone alors personne ne
s'entraînent personne de santé trop
attention c'est parti vite tu peux qu
elle a été traitée très bien et très
bien l'affairé isabelle telle à la bombe
et données insérées l'on peut pas
s'asseoir février m le bâtonnet cette
rangée invitait les btan mr power est ce
qu on peut taper quelqu'un pour qu'il
sorte non non alors on un peu c'est pas
ça s'est passé pour toi qu'elle ait
besoin d'une boule à l'infini quoi les
boules allez-y c'est parti merci c'est
tout le même organisationnel alors vous
le disent les trois derniers seront
éliminés parce que si l'on va jouer
demain
g locales ont su wei dong de gueule on
découvre alors les 4 6 2 8 12
zenio nissan à la sde wc fait centre de
gravité non c'est pas mal
dabul merci allez on enchaîne garde de
boules ou les oreilles quand vous serez
tranquillement chez vous ça pinaille
bâtiment benayen médaille pour l'instant
c'est kelly et benhaim qui sont éliminés
on va en éliminer quatre tous éliminés
quatre mazurkas direct fixe ou pas un
jour tu vois tu auras salir site mais
pas jusqu'au c'est parti magie sujet se
calme on se calme je sais que c'est un
tournoi important
nous on se calme et je le rappelle chez
vous si vous nous suivez bien sûr je
rappelle la règle sauf qu'à ses boules
éliminer ce que c'est également comme ça
dans la vie normale et votre robot le
problème toujours il est éliminé
très bien il ne restera plus alors là
donc elle n'a plus trop à éliminer sur
ce truc comme ça
iranienne est éliminée c'est sûr aller
attention c'est parti alors si vous
voulez plus secs etc et moins lourds et
viandés parce que je voudrais maintenant
que vous savez m a pas besoin
d'apprendre de traque aux essais pour
équilibrer on fait toujours de gravité
on regarde où on va bien on plombe je le
sens pas cet abruti
l'attaqué de la résidence avant tout
chez nous les ménages
[Applaudissements]
sur le cac c'est pire alors regardez
mais la menace et la voilà à casser
venez la voilà au plus près de la
rochelle ancien voilà casser un oeuf
casser ses marques et des maracas et les
rênes touchés non non vous levin et
c'est quoi la une caméra on dirait que
tu peux plus je vais retenir les
britanniques vont dire les règles
calmez vous et vous êtes gentil que je
remette de balles preuve atomu le débo
pente et concentrés voilà éliminé faire
mieux voilà j'étais jean pierre jeantet
coach a fait un ace non rester au canada
allez c'est parti c'est maxime savais
attaquer balagué ni ça passe on vend des
dvd 4 ayad al jazeera des nouvelles
plombent ça roule beaucoup sans les
toucher 2 ans tombée que tu fais on
attends je vais parce que l'été à
saint-tropez vanille
[Applaudissements]
olala castaldi au castaldi qui passe
entre 20 c bon avec bénabar et de cd
baissent on est dans une émission là oui
on est en direct un bien sûr excuses moi
la traîne un mec qui se lavent les noms
mais tellement je vais avoir des jeunes
évolue viable bazire est mis au pas les
passer au brixia commence à me faire ch
merci merci à l'aide par bénabar et moi
c'est maxime de l'argent ne sens pas de
voiture mais il y aura vente mais rien
tirer de leur taille va dire s'ils
allaient aller d'autres génies tour on
doit donc importer autre tube est barrée
que telenet y voit augusto cd je dis
donc tu perds ton slip pouponner passé
d'autres hugh macdonald et j'ai
d'ailleurs parmi nous merci attention à
l'homme c'est bon c'est mon frère on a
les attentions
pour l'instant les éliminer bayador a
dit michel castaldi
mélanie mme kelly
c'est voilà on a perdu benabadji
milliard on a perdu l'habitude par aird
ça se complique genre on vénère voilà au
merci je suis qualifié ce week-end ça
sort ça ceccaldi il sort un jeu ce soir
si donc les caps sortis eux
je vais vous demander de prendre le rer
et de rentrer chez moi sont pour
l'instant tous les autres d'ailleurs non
on va alors je vais vous dire nbim
journal illumine deux autres parce que
on est vrai c'est que lorsque les deux
terminé d'accords mets de la toile
merci ça vous alerte pas la ga des mines
et du scrutin les ont chacun une chance
pour se qualifier
il reste aussi allez vous prenez alors
est ce ses maîtresses rêve est
mécanicien métal et planifié mettez vous
rappelle qu'il ya smartphone
exceptionnel et gagner le derby face à
annaba c'est pour toi qu'on a fait tout
ça alors c'est isabelle morini bosc
avait dit allez y à aller alors
attention mobile ebeam 2a les izards
après ce sera comment ignorer cela comme
il ya moi aussi vraiment pas verni cher
quartier avec percy combinant massif six
ans creusant des ligneux allait aller
vite et qui est mis en scène à enchaîner
et la télé vite qui va gagner ce
championnat
on élimine deux je rappelle henri guaino
a dit gainey m'a dit guennoun attention
basi guennoun merci jean mimi merci à
levac mathieu mathieu mathieu lauffray
mathieu et toi avec les deux me saluer
on y va ce sera toujours ça vous donne
tout oui ça va gagner obbadi grémont non
je déconne non mais arrêtez s'il vous
plaît on n'est pas là pour ça on n'est
pas là allez c'est parti
attention qui va hélas aura deux
éliminés comme on s'amuse avec aurillac
c'était beau c'était beau non non non
alors est ce qu'on me dit qu'il ya eu
une erreur je suis éliminé
j'avoue je vois tension et isa les
quatre derniers sa classe dans le
smartphone ça ma soeur ouais bon allez
va jours commence ma dévotion à léonie
attention hélas les chéris le gagnant va
se jouer maintenant
paniqué le gagnant c'est maintenant
qu'on va le connaît ok avant qu'on doit
on va faire deux éliminés aux pressions
a deux ennemis n'offre à la finale les
gens adorent allez c'est parti
quand quatre victoires je donne à
personne et à sa série a je garde pour
moi
ben non ça on s'en doutait nous
connaissez bien de préciser aller en de
boules pour l' équilibre mais non mais
c'est pas ça va mais les mecs excuse moi
tu as ton émission et mon livre attend
ça t'as pas de regrets voilà la poussée
vieille d'une régulation suprême à l'âge
doit pas faire pire au maxim's vide et
c'est sûr allez allez raymond tchimou
raymond finale et je rappelle que le
gagnant devra désigner celui qui sera en
cochonné jusqu'à la fin de l'émission il
devra commencer toutes ces parties
affrontements cochonnet cochonnet sans
cochonou cette association
[Applaudissements]
alors attends je rajoute une règle tu
peux taper sur sa boule et si elle gas
l'allergique c'est toi qui gagnent sur
la qui viendront il n'y a jamais
vraiment si je te le symbole est ce cas
ce n'est pas légal alors on est là on la
remet la boue et brett et culture rom et
la boule et enlève la boule de maxime
allais voilà si tu arrives à pousser sa
boule
c'était quelqu'un 109 à huy a fait un
quart au fc chooz la haye
[Applaudissements]
dis nous tout de suite qui tue mais en
cochonnet ils sont plus de minutes alors
non bombe alors tu m'a dit vas-y dit
pourquoi toi tu as envie d'être
cochonnet ou pas mais je n'ai vu tourner
la tête vers moi j'ai soupçonné qu'elle
allait vite choisir moi alors au mas on
va venir sur hbo gynéco mais juste vous
pourquoi pas vous choisir basque
isabelle on est on est très ancien dans
l'émission toi et moi dont je pense même
dans la vie et la carrière démarre mal
une solidarité qui s'impose on est tous
les deux journalistes voyez je connais
pas de points communs ont ce qu'ils font
habituellement donc je ne sais pas mais
devenu qu'il choisisse que celle choisie
c'est la vie je tomberai pas pire
défense possible
alors toi quelqu'un de gentil moi
j'accepte de le faire beaucoup de
plaisir il est trop gentil
bachiri le truand ferrer lui alors merde
que ce soit quelqu'un qui est pas envie
de nous parce que ça fait de la peine
bah oui et moi non mais tu sais combien
il avait tué alors vraiment isabelle tu
es sûr que tu m'as oui j'en ai joué vous
désignez disent ah bah oui elle m'a dit
non sinon je désigne
[Rires]
ah oui bah oui capable de faire des
saloperies après me jean michel bardet
c'est jean-michel merci